hello and welcome to three scary games
i'm gonna hit you with the jumpscare now
we're gonna start off with whitehaven
prologue demo my name is rachel and i
live at the whitehaven orphanage two
days ago my friend claire tried to leave
the orphanage and she hasn't come back
to our room yet
i'm very worried i managed to get the
room keys from the reception closet
and i'm going to get out of here tonight
do you say that you're a resident of an
orphanage
live in an orphanage i have no idea
hi this is mr cotton i'll leave him here
so the monsters won't hurt him
the monsters you say
okay
okay i always like to slam doors in my
face when i open them
you know orphanages aren't automatically
creepy
but this is a little creepy why don't i
have an actual flashlight i thought i
picked that up
i don't seem to have the ability to
actually use it nor do i have the
ability to run
at all okay i should not be going into
the dark i'm not going to go into the
darkness why would i go into the
darkness
when i have a perfectly good and
well-lit stairwell
we don't get a lot of sun here do we
okay
is anybody running this place
why are the lights left on
man it's kind of dark is there any way
to turn on the flashlight
am i crazy
oh no oh there we go
it's autumn magical oh good
oh great i always wanted to escape this
place
why going in the basement also those are
the most rickety stairs i've ever seen
in my life
whoever was building that handrail was
clearly drunk high
and also dead okay something's gonna
jump out
around the corner it will not open
because there is no electricity
yeah that makes sense in an orphanage
perfect hi
don't mind me doing the shuffle out of
here
you have a good day now you have a good
day
oh the boiler
the boiler is about to blow wow
trapped back here today these doors only
open one way
all right sure i'll investigate why that
guy was shuffling off down the hallway
here
grandpa grandma
fine not a big deal
white haven orphanage the white haven
orphanage is a non-profit institution
for abandoned children here they will be
able to develop and grow together at
both
in an academic and social environment
since 1875 we have taken care of all of
these unfortunate little ones thanks to
your donations
our facility allows children to access a
large number of services some of which
include
primary and secondary education
tutorials and personalized support
gym and play areas library nursing and
periodic medical checkups
socialization and integration sessions
wow
those sound way too official for dealing
with children
i love it when my children get social
and
something integration
i guess the ideas that are not my
children because they're
orphans why you lock
hey was it unlocked now what's going on
there
okay still locked okay good good good
good good that's great that's great
that's good
was that clear i hope she's already far
from here
oh well it doesn't sound like she is if
you heard her scream from behind
that door i'm just gonna spell it out
for you
claire not doing so good that's the
answer to that equation
you ever pondered that don't ponder too
hard because the answer's right in front
of your face
or rub behind you and you're walking
away from it i don't even know why i
tried to get out in the basement anyway
who does that go out the front door the
frontis doris
am i going out here wherever what am i
doing am i just trying to leave now
well this is gonna be locked isn't it
yeah it's gonna be locked
what were you thinking what was i
thinking i was the one that navigated up
there
why blame myself when i can blame others
for my own mistakes
that's the markiplier way okay well oh
petrol can i have that now
did i need that for something like
say petrol do i get it there was a gas
can over here
or a drum of gas i'm assuming
this this thing right here
no this
this should be enough for what
also i don't think this
are you telling me this freaking propane
tank
is also a generator is that what you're
trying to
explain to me
yeah fair enough you know what who am i
to complain who am i to criticize
oh it's on oh yeah yeah
well that's a weird rug
it's raining i need to find something to
help me reach that window
like this bookshelf that's right in
front of the window
boxes are too heavy i can't move them i
am a child after all
bookshelf uh some old history books i
always loved that subject
really not the time really not the time
could i climb that i can't even jump
well looks like i am done here
uh maybe there was something over in the
storage room
there was a ladder there was a ladder
i do remember that everything's fine
because i have a ladder i found the lag
fine that's fine i'm not going near that
i don't know if you wanted me to but my
instincts say no
i don't care how enticing your freaking
used tv is close the door
place the ladder and escape i go
freedom oh where did you come from
oh there we go thank you for playing
prologue of whitehaven in the final
version you will be able to explore the
orphanage in its entirety
you'll find puzzles mysteries to be
solved and much more horror
if you have enjoyed the experience don't
forget to add the game to your wish list
not too shabby not shabby at all had a
few jumps had a few scares
just like this one this is called
walking home alone
which is something that we've all had to
do at some point in our lives
bam fire fire what am i firing
don't forget your keypad code am i
supposed to remember that
now follow the lit path home okay number
one my first question is why is this my
path home and number two
how did i get dropped into this path
with nothing where did i come from
where am i going am i the mythical
cotton i
joe i got a good feeling about this one
i got a great feeling about this one
i got a good feeling about this one
was my home a gingerbread house in the
middle of the woods
what am i doing why do i live out here
i mean i know i get wanting seclusion
and all that but
why or did i just decide to take a
shortcut through the woods to get back
home
objective updated follow the lit fence
oh damn
that fence is lit
oh oh well that's
okay you're actually real i didn't know
if you were just going to be a
hallucination or something
man did i not realize what i was getting
myself into when i bought this damn
house
is that my is that my home is i really
do
nine five seven eight plus enter
nine five seven eight plus enter okay
all right here we go let's see if we can
get it
all right we'll we'll try it he use
nine five seven eight enter what nine
five seven eight and
what oh no oh nine
five seven eight enter
oh my god i'm dead open the door
i'm being chopped
you made it but you also died sorry
about that
this is my first poof of concept game
i wanted to create a good atmosphere in
one stressful situation if you liked it
and want more please let me know
you know honestly not bad you know not
bad it was stressful it was pretty
stressful you lied to me
you lied to me you lied to me
you lied to me but i love that [ __ ] you
know more of those if you guys just want
to make a proof of concept thing
freaking make it that's awesome i like
that anyway here's another jump scare
all right welcome to lights off space to
start i'm gonna space to start
night one oh [ __ ]
night one oh
switch off all the lights and go to bed
all right the frame rate kind of looks
slow but it actually isn't low
all right well at least this is uh one
of several games that are teaching us
all to be conscious of the power bill
that's dark
nice house though you know honestly not
bad
not sure why all these lights were on
but it's all good it's all good
okay bedtime it is oh
hmm
don't like that
do you guys see anything in the darkness
i too go from directly awake to
immediately asleep
i'm asleep now oh it's just that easy
good good
switch off all the lights and go to bed
of course
of course i'll do that of course i will
of course and nothing's going to be
different because this is just a coming
home from work simulator
ah
that's fine it's fine it's fine
it's totally fine that's totally fine
that's totally fine
that's totally fine
yay hooray
time for bed
resting my head resting my head
i am in bed i am in bed
resting my head i am in bed
i'm in bed well i hate this for some
reason
how is something so simplistic and
nothing's happening so terrifying to me
i don't know switch off all the lights
and go to bed okay
i'm going to do exactly that let's make
it happen captain
what's with the noises
that's why that's fine that's fine
that's fine also what freak what freak
does not have a door on their bedroom
what kind of freak i'm going to sleep
like a week i'm asleep i'm awake
i'm awake i sleep
i'm asleep i'm awake obviously
i'm asleep it's fine
totally fine very restful night of sleep
that i got then
at that moment very restful so restful
all right anyway back home from another
day of work
tough day tough day
tough day tough day tough day
tough day real tough day
really tough really tough day can't wait
to
lay my head
you okay in there yeah
that's nothing that's that's aunt sally
you guys see anything okay
you guys see anything
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] do i see
anything in the darkness
okay and we're asleep and just like that
it's like magic
nothing gives you a better night's rest
than fear
this isn't going to bed after a long
night's a day's work
oh i hate this oh i hate this
oh i hey oh what
is this
who's death mine who's death
since when do i have an upbeat stairsy
since when have i always had that oh god
i hope i haven't
oh no oh no
oh no
death visits death visits
i love death visits
i guess i gotta find a few of these
things
sure
oh preemptively
oh i'm passing out i'm just so tired
yeah okay oh wow switch off
all right you know all right all right
this seems good i like this this is
good stuff oh
can i take more pictures can i get a
door ah
time for bed time to lay my head down
oh
hey
[Music]
wow you got a stumpy leg
i should have gotten the door
i'm asleep now you can't keep me i'm
asleep
that's how it works i'm immune
i'm immune to you
and i'm dead apparently or i'm alive
it was all a dream
i loved that terrible awful horrible but
i loved it
excellent stuff jump scare
this is the whitetail instant i'm doing
four games just because that one game
was so short it was more just a proof of
concept than anything so i'm going to
play another one right here
that also says that it's short we should
have heard back from him by now
i'm sure he's fine that call was
probably just kids making things up
either that or they just saw nothing
i'm just being paranoid there's nothing
else out here anyway
if something's gone wrong jonathan has a
shotgun this looks like the place
what are you talking about and who you
talking to
[Music]
okay
oh hot dog
oh this game is already the best
oh look at that dog look at that dog
excellent i love that i love that i love
that so much
that's beautiful doggie coming with oh
boochie boochie all right boochie
let's go i feel better hey look it's a
deer
bang
all right i'll just be on my way
nothing strange about this environment
oh hey it's a camp
oh hey it's blood booty you see anything
nope
who do you see anything about the blood
blood bother you at all
i love that there's a dog with me
instantly not scary at all
instantly no ski oh
bottom something has caused him to bleed
out possibly a wild animal attack
he must have been one of the campers
that called us what do you think pop
good idea keep going what do we have
here
shouting bad must have happened for
jonathan to leave his shotgun here
i need to find him i got three bullets
and a doggy not i'm not gonna shoot the
dog that's for damn sure
okay you're not a zombie are you okay
you better not be
hmm well i got a bad feeling about this
maybe there's something down this way
oh my god oh my god i've never
i've never been more worried than that
oh
hope i will kill anybody that hurt that
dog i will destroy everything
i'm no longer afraid i'm vengeful and
angry
[Music]
hi who wants some
are you all naked
what the hell is going on here looks
like they're performing some kind of
ritual
jonathan's still alive i need to save
him okay
i got three bullets who wants it
i am okay oh i have more bullets
bam ow boom i'm here to save you buddy
hey jonathan what's wrong with him he
looks like he's possessed
oh there you are pop oh my god
oh wait so the pup was with me the whole
time wait okay come back
wait wait i didn't see the what it what
i don't have enough bullets for you oh
god oh god okay just gonna run
running
i don't think i have anything oh yes
please thank you
ow bang oh
oh god damn it okay let's run i i should
have
probably there were more shotgun shells
down there okay
um whoa shotgun shells and beans this
was beans
bang a boom
ah damn it there's more
hey can i get out of here
where's the dog where's the dog tell me
there's a dog here
dog dog what am i doing what am i
looking for
what's happening here oh
that doesn't look good yeah suddenly
they take more than one shot which i
think is completely unfair
shotgun chill shotgun
i got to hit him like dead center of
mass like straight on
can of beans can of beans can of beans
oh
shotgun shells over there but it's too
late didn't think that today was going
to be so murdery
more shout gun shells yes please can the
beans don't don't
nope
there must have been more up here i
don't know if i need to kill them all
seems a little excessive but whatever
when in rome and when in the deadly
force of whatever the hell place this is
boom
there we go okay now where the hell did
the dog go and where the hell did that
guy go
jonathan jonathan jonathan get back here
you sassy [ __ ]
okay so i'm here oh oh now i can go
poppy puppy oh
well sorry jonathan you uh
oh ow oh ow wow
what the hell don't do that wow oh my
god
oh my god you suck what the hell
ah goddammit i didn't get this
no god damn it oh my god if you kill me
oh if you kill me after all this
i swear ah i'm dead really really oh
shoot your legs out from under you
that's what i'll do
bring around the rosie ring around the
rosie i'm gonna catch up to you [ __ ]
you think you're faster than me the
answer is probably yes oh apparently yes
absolutely you are oh no you're not no
you're not no you're not
oh [ __ ] got him
okay and then just gotta be smooth about
it oh you're stuck oh you're not stuck
come on go down alright oh just got you
[ __ ]
just got you that's a tough deer
hop up hi you want dinner
dinner poppy hi poochie
you really helped me out there the
emotional support was everything
thank you well there you have it
more of like a campy 80s horror but i
kind of like it
you know i'm not too much in combat in
horror games but you could definitely
have it there's
there's nothing wrong with having it i
like the style i like the gameplay it
was pretty fun
i think i was a very enjoyable yeah not
bad
not bad
[Music]
all right so that was three scary games
i'm gonna hit you with a jump scare and
then we're gonna get out of here all
right
[Music]
you